pied gauche devant et main droite en
haut voilà
la plupart de ces jeunes découvrent la
perche et la façon de s'en servir pour
s'élever
si la course et les lancers sont assez
populaire et pratiquer cette discipline
est méconnu et pourtant elle peut
devenir addictives
au départ on a peur mais on y revient
parce qu'on a parce qu'on a peur et que
l'instant où on a décollé c'est un petit
peu la magie on est on n'est plus maître
de sens et c'est plus l'unique force de
ses jambes
c'est restitués par la perche donc c'est
un petit peu un petit moment de magie la
queue qui durent pas longtemps avec les
jeunes veulent veulent reproduire en
fait la perche s'est aussi allié de la
rapidité est un peu d'acrobaties du côté
des enfants
passées les premières craintes chacun
s'amuse et demande à recommencer au
début sans fil mais voir le 4 5 il faut
prendre des weiland pourquoi tu as eu
peur de pas y arriver parce que j'ai
peur que je vais tomber ça s'est bien
passé
est ce que ça t'a plu pourquoi ça t'as
plus sauter ça faisait bien à la très
bien tu viens de suspendre sur tes mains
et la perche a bien des vertus et des à
synchroniser le haut et le bas du corps
trouvé un équilibre se concentrer elle
peut séduire chaque public
ça va être un saut vers l'avant on est
souvent en hauteur est donc là on va
aller dans un endroit qu'est plus bas
d'où on est parti donc la confiance ça
il joue énormément on a vu au début les
gens qui tremblaient pour les premiers
secours certains ce qu on est un endroit
on est un peu haut on va arriver on ne
sait pas trop comment une perche pour la
plupart ils ont jamais fait donc la
perche et le sport en général c'est un
développement de la confiance et qui
sait ces jeunes seront peut-être un jour
les athlètes du perche élite tour